the iron bank dates from when Braavos
was still the secret city filled with
Runaways and refugees from the Valyrian
slave Lords the first tradesmen to
achieve success realized that if they
pooled their resources they could loan
money to their less fortunate fellows
and build a better Braavos for a profit
of course first they needed a space to
store their combined gold
safe from thieves and more importantly
each other for the business rivalries
that created their fortunes were not
easily put aside they found an abandoned
iron mine outside the city and sealed
its only entrance with heavy gates and
bars and said guards supplied by every
principal investor each guard watched
the gate and the other guards over time
this distrust vanished as the investors
gave up their other businesses and
poured their energies into the new
endeavor now called the iron back after
the mine we've since moved to more
spacious quarters but we still keep our
first vault not merely to remind us of
our roots but because we did not become
the world's greatest repository of
wealth by wasting assets no matter how
minor if you're an aspiring merchant you
come to us to buy ships and goods if
you're an aspiring shopkeeper you can't
have us to buy your shop whatever you
need in this world we are the conduit
even a throne can be yours if you're an
aspiring King or stay yours if you're a
sitting one just gas house Lannister and
Westeros we are not the only bank in
this world every free city has its own
but when those banks need gold they come
to us we lend to princes kings merchants
and tradesmen if a prince or King can
pay us back
well the world lacks for loyal men not
ambitious ones we simply fund the rise
of new princes and kings and they tend
to honor our investment if a merchant
refuses to repay us well the
vicissitudes of trade are well known and
Braavos is full of men
who are not one way or another the iron
bank will have its due